a week after i finished Ranger School I
was an Oxford and I had the sunken
cheeks in the shaved head I think my
peers didn't quite know what to make of
me especially in those early weeks when
I just finished Ranger School and you
know I get the advice really on coming
back from Oxford that going back to the
infantry I'd have to out soldier
everyone else to be taken seriously I
think I had why had one run-in with a
superior officer who you know we ended
up settling it by blows
was there any gear you found while you
were there that was particularly helpful
to you all of the night vision boots
that are hardy enough and have enough
ankle support so you can go up these you
know 60 degrees slopes on these rock and
we have these almost like laser pointers
only they were they could go for a much
longer distance with a higher powered
laser and if you want to identify where
you were you know it's in two aircraft
you could just sort of make a lasso in
the air the up armored Humvees I mean I
wish we'd had I wish we'd had more often
we were using these toyota pickup trucks
because we didn't have the Humvees we
need would you want to drive around
where you think their IDs in a ford
ranger it's hard to imagine until you're
on the ground how difficult it is to
move even a short distance I mean one
firefight we were in the another unit
had come in contact 30 kilometers away
and that can I took us four hours to get
there and many places there are no roads
and if there is a road it's a it's a
dirt road with potholes that'll swallow
Humvee I mean looking back at that tour
I guess of the sacrifice maybe we left
you know we left people behind people
were hurt and you want to know that it
was for a reason I was at a base in
eastern Afghanistan and they were there
a handful of guys around a based who
were thickly muscled Eveleigh bearded
well tanned and had some pretty
impressive gear and you didn't ask a lot
of questions and if you ask their name
was usually Chris or John the one
incident and I described in the book
it's when they're they're ambushed and
they take you know they take a couple
Afghan casualties and and in the process
of clearing this valley Chris Chris one
of the operators was killed
and I watch them bleed out in front of
me you know they say the best tactics in
the world won't matter if you have the
strategy wrong and I think in two
thousand three at a time when we didn't
officially recognized that there was an
insurgency in Afghanistan the strategy
was wrong and so those tactical
successes that great sacrifice didn't
amount to much difference in the overall
picture in Afghanistan you have to marry
the kinetic operations the ambushes and
the raids to the soft side operations
because you're only going to get the
intelligence you need to do the kinetic
stuff if you have the support of the
local population you know I described it
a bit as it's like throwing darts in a
dark room I mean sometimes you hit the
bullseye but you don't deserve to and
this was the sort of trial and error
trying to find al Qaeda many instances
driving around waiting to get shot and
it was a failure maybe then we didn't
have success in the counter terror
mission and we lost ground in terms of
the support of the population there's
the talibans sort of safe areas in
Pakistan and of course the u.s. the way
they've been addressing going after
those safe areas is with these with
these drone strikes do they make sense
to you there are advantages to being
able to to strike remotely at at key
leadership inside Pakistan
but when you try to pan back and look
strategically you know what is what does
that do for the recruiting base of the
Taliban in Pakistan Afghanistan what
does that do for the ability of al-qaeda
to reconstitute you're balancing the
political stability of Pakistan against
the sort of the military advantages of
making these counter terrorist strikes
not sure what the answer is